this'll song and dance
I won't do the song or the dance lately
there's been a lot of helicopters flying
over my house late at night that's a
really soothing thing for someone that's
already wildly paranoid of being
kidnapped I need to take a bath when you
have helicopters flying over your house
at night
talk about a relaxing time hi guys
welcome to Friday re-fry tyree if you
don't know look back in my weekend vlog
forum here are some of the things that
I've done this week and I will warn you
it wasn't a lot of documented things I
keep getting really bad at friary
because snapchat exists Malik said I
wasn't the best on snapchat this week
either I think I've just been doing a
lot of DIY classic excute and the Steven
Avery should have said he was doing some
very tasteful DIY wasn't doing any DI
eo4 diary it is Sunday and that means
it's time to organize my life for a
brief moment in time for like I'm doing
things and also to procrastinate from
the stuff I really should be doing so
look you saw last week that I redid my
desk and I have even redone some stuff
in it since that video I have added more
plants to this wall and today we are
tackling this closet look this is this
closet currently yes Wow and I just got
back from Home Depot and got some
closets [ __ ] things and stuff but I'm
going to try to install in this place
and see what happens I've measured
nothing I just purchased things that
look like they could fit I love my home
renovations like scratch off ticket who
knows what's gonna happen but you go in
with the best intentions and usually
pretty disappointed hey let's try some
Wow Wow well hello and happy Monday to
all of you guys
it is 9:25 I have to be somewhere at 10
a.m.
and I just woke up not too long ago so I
in an effort to try and vlog more this
week I thought that I would cut my short
time getting ready even shorter by
bringing you guys along with me in this
getting ready process what am I getting
ready for I'm going to record the
audiobook version of my new book Grace
and style the art of pretending you have
it then - dad I'm sick of me talking
about this yet well I hope you find a
remedy for that sickness that when we
talking about it a lot for the next
month let's start getting ready to quote
Beyonce or whoever said this I woke up
like this
true story here's one thing I do when I
feel really tired I put this thing on oh
wow first aid beauty detox I roller you
put it under your eyes and it stings a
little bit and that's how I believe it's
working my battery is flashing so you
just might get cut off in the middle of
this I don't mean to be rude I'm just
ill prepared my hair is gonna go like
this
and it takes a lot to maintain a mess
dry shampoo I use doves hair therapy dry
shampoo because it smells like doves no
it does it does our Birds no prints
smell bad but oh my gosh yeah then we do
this in my mirror like that's gonna help
this is my second cup of espresso for
the day that's a great beauty tip it
helps align your chakras and loosen your
Bohol oh boy this is called am I trying
gonna turn this thing on because
a go-getter why am I tired this morning
and why was it difficult to wake up
because I was up till 3:00 a.m. looking
up how to best Feng Shui your bedroom
and I ended up ordering a bamboo fern
and another Himalayan sea salt lamp on
and the Sun at 3:30 a.m. it's all about
balance
yours all my makeup tinted moisturizer
from Laura Mercier just smash it on
there maybe I've tweeted this already
but if I haven't get a life hack for lip
scrub just smash cinnamon toast crunch
into your face at 8:30 a.m. on repeat
the cinnamon particles really scrub the
dead skin I've been going back to you
some makeup for ever HD foundation and I
like it next I'm all aboard this train
and I don't even know if they sold me a
ticket
Becker under eye brightener corrector
look at that Wow whatever you are you do
a cool job I think I don't know if I'm
putting this on correctly smash that in
there boom next eyebrows I got my Urban
Decay the brow box I usually go for
darker brows and they can tend to look
like angry emoji eyebrows sometimes so
I'm trying a little lighter color to see
if that makes any difference and if you
guys stop leaving comments saying that
my eyebrows are too aggressive I mean
thank you for your criticism it's
constructive and helpful and ultimately
leads me to a better version of myself
but also if you look kindly off that
would be really nice I use the Anastasia
Beverly Hills clear brow gel just to
lock it down it's like if you like you
put a ring on it and if you really like
it put some clear brow gel on it now on
to bronzer Park Avenue princess by Tarte
it's my favorite bronzer I use it all
the time and you might be asking grace
why are you doing your makeup to go
record an audio book isn't that just
your voice and not your face yes that is
true
but I am wildly insecure I'll deal with
my issues if you deal with yours now on
to blush
oh my new favorite blush that I have
been loving is this a brand know what
it's Bobby Brown's and I guess it's
called a boy they're going at an
Illumina
bronzing powder but it looks like a bra
brush it looks like a blush to me it's
an antigua - got a blush you call that a
bronzer Bobby Bobby does my Hank Hill
impression now on to mascara brand tried
this Lancome Hypnose drama from Lancome
whoa look at that weird damn I'm not
gonna put anything my lips because I'm
still drinking this coffee and I gotta
brush my teeth that's my basic everyday
makeup situation I got to leave in mmm
how to fake fix your fashion faux pas
optimistically speaking we're all
whirling dervishes a potential disaster
at the same time we're all the dragon
tools of potential disaster relief with
stuff we fix it it's a circle of life
just ask any emotionally unstable yet
very light for his age monkey from The
Lion King hello
happy Tuesday I just recorded the second
and final half of my audio book this
morning and I'm rewarding myself with
plants but they take up so much space
because we're getting this stuff for
other projects at the house that the
only you see that look Wow
yes much plants and then there's another
one bye buddy
and then here's one hi buddy who needs
cats when you have plans
oh hello friary happy Wednesday to you
all I'm on my way right now to see a
good dear friend of mine Larry King the
book promotional stuff has begun I've
been doing a couple interviews here and
there and right now we are gonna go to
the set of the Larry King show I don't
know the official title but I know on
Twitter he's very active at Kings things
so go tweet at him and tell him that I
said hello I guess I don't know well
don't be I mean don't bother also last
time I got to talk to him was when I was
doing promotion for the e talk show and
he gave me some of the greatest advice
about being a host and I'll never forget
it because he subscribes to the same
Church of thought that I do which is
that we don't know anything a good
interviewer someone that's genuinely
curious about the people they're talking
to and he really made me believe he was
curious to me so let's see if it happens
again yeah
we can unreal yeah what a juxtaposition
oh yeah who needs abs and you've got
Tiger scratch tiger scratches are so
2016 it's all for the art like for life
whoa way my Amanda steel on my way to
steal your girl just kidding you can
have your girl you guys seem like a
lovely lovely couple hello friary good
morning it is Thursday morning and I met
it to a meeting its 1004 a.m. I was
supposed to be at the meeting at 10 a.m.
good thing being on time was not the new
year's resolution for mine
this chick is swollen from yesterday I
went to the dentist Hey
saved you guys the trouble of having to
watch me go to the dentist but instead
I'll give you guys the trouble of
telling you about going to the dentist
watch the dentist to get a permanent
crown finally but my temporary crown
unbeknownst to the dentist when I didn't
tell them fell off when I was in
Australia and I didn't get it replaced
so my gums grew over my tooth a little
bit and my teeth shifted so the
permanent crown didn't fit so I had to
get another mold done and another
temporary crown put in and they really
shoved that mother sure deep into the
gums in the back and so my head has been
aching in my mouth is sore and life is
just sucking now life is pretty cool at
this meeting and then I'm going home
after this oh I got a new yellow chair
show you guys that so
foreshadowing except not for shadow I'm
just telling you exactly what's
happening in the future
anticipation yellow chair what kind of
yellow chair could it be this content is
off the charts
who needs making a murderer when you
have a grey Celtics frie diary just so
you know guys on tinder only like to
date girls with chlamydia hey where'd
you get your shoes style and selection
what yes yes I what
hello guys welcome back to my car and
right now I am in the parking lot of a
Michaels I just did a lot of damage
hands off it's my staff okay because I'm
going on book tour I'm trying to plan
out some videos and get them shot
beforehand which is something I'm not
good at because I like to wait to the
very last minute until that intense
pressure and anxiety of having to put up
a video creates creativity I went into
Michael's trying to get some stuff for
Valentine's Day ideas and for some DIY
ideas I think I have about 50 different
ideas that are at about 10% each in
these bags rather than like five ideas
at a hundred percent so we'll see what
happens I guess it's two hours later and
things have developed I found the jo-ann
fabrics on the way home and I bought
myself a sewing machine I'm just
becoming a stereotype okay yeah I made
it this is the status post Michaels and
jo-ann fabrics I have made Chester and I
gave a thrones outfit because he was I
am king of the Cheetos okay snacks and
this is your court jester so that's the
progress and all of the good work that
I've done this evening
wild beast okay the other thing I've
done so far is I switch that thing from
one they look like that before and then
I switched it to that and oh look look
the infamous chair look at this it's a
yellow chair you guys Wow oh you know
what else I didn't do I didn't show you
the closet after remember this from the
beginning of the week look at that I
know it just still looks like a mess
right now but it's far more organized um
what else is gonna happen I'm gonna
plant a bunch of videos I'm gonna see if
I can make this sewing machine work
because I bought some fabric that I am
very excited to make into a pillow this
is what it looks like
it's hamburgers what else oh this also
came in the mail and I forgot that I
ordered this this week I am style icon
so I just want you guys to remember that
and I think this will help you remember
I got this shirt ordered this off of the
internet 100% sober and I think it's a
great choice I'm very pleased with
myself I'm gonna eat some salad and try
and make a sewing machine work can I get
more Shing feminine hi guys here's
another update it's been a couple hours
maybe and a hamburger pillow has been
made has any real progress in my life
happen on a professional level you tell
me look I'm doing Amberg or cosplay well
there you go there was a look back at my
week and some of the things that I've
done I hope you guys had a wonderful
wonderful week if you haven't checked
out already go to Grace style book calm
so you can see all of the places that
will be going to on tour across the
United States
I'm sorry other countries I know you
guys are really upset but there might be
more stuff added I'm still waiting to
see it's not my choice I hope you can
really believe that I didn't sit in a
room with everyone help plan the storm
was like absolutely no other country I
only go to the United States if you are
just showered in your own bitterness
about me not coming to your country over
your town or your state then you should
pre-order the book because that is a
really great pick-me-up you want to know
what else is a really great pick-me-up
ah like and subscribe I don't know I
have been turning on this Himalayan salt
lamp that my mom got me for Christmas
every day don't know if it's doing
anything but it's a real pretty placebo
that's my stripper name that or jelly
boners